maintenant, la chose que vous ne saurez pas à propos de cette
Mini Cooper, c'est qu'elle est petite, nous sommes en
proportion moi et ma voiture, je m'appelle
Robert Rice, j'étais secrétaire au travail
sous Bill Clinton avant l'
administration Carter, avant cela, j'étais
un assistant spécial pour  Abraham Lincoln de tous
les pays développés, les États-Unis ont
la répartition des revenus la plus inégale
ont augmenté vers une inégalité encore plus grande
1928 et 2007 sont devenues les
années de pointe pour la concentration des revenus, cela ressemble
à un pont suspendu l'année dernière, nous avons
fait trente-six mille en avons probablement
fait cinquante mille  année de travail 70
heures par semaine la classe moyenne a du
mal les gens
me disent parfois quelle nation fait mieux la
réponse est les États-Unis dans les
décennies qui ont suivi la Seconde Guerre mondiale l'économie a
explosé là où vous aviez de très faibles inégalités
vous savez Robert Reich je le fais  c'est un
communiste quand j'étais un gamin de
plus grands garçons en devenant je pense que ça a
changé ma vie je devais protéger les gens
des gens qui les battraient
économiquement qui s'occupe réellement
du travailleur américain la réponse est que
personne les
travailleurs n'ont de pouvoir s'ils
n'ont pas voix au chapitre leurs salaires et avantages sociaux
commencent à s'éroder nous perdons l'égalité des
chances en Amérique quiconque d'entre vous
se sent cynique considère simplement  où nous
avons été
vous